hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprise
surprise there's a new black costume
wearing reverse-flash on the flash
season 3 so this is gonna be some
speculation about who he could be
because in keeping with tradition I
think they're combining a lot of like
really cool-looking costumes from
different heirs of the flash with very
identifiable villains that people will
recognize so there's a couple big
characters that this could be we're
doing flashpoint this season so you know
one this could just be an alternate
version of a character we've already
seen I don't necessarily think that that
is the case but I do think in keeping
with the idea that the flash tries to be
really easy to follow for people who
don't read comics that he's gonna have a
really big name in just a different
looking costume than that character that
he's playing had in the comics so
they're just mixing and matching a lot
of things like right now let's think of
him as Wally West's reverse-flash the
flashpoint reverse-flash there have been
pictures from behind the scenes with his
hood off and it looks like an actor from
Vampire Diaries that's like everyone
wants best cast I refuse to watch
Vampire Diaries but the actor in
question played a villain
during season 7 so I'm guessing that
what they're doing this season is that
they're not gonna recycle the theme of
wolf in sheep's clothing
like they'll have their reverse flash
but he's not gonna secretly pretend to
be one of their friends so it won't be
like you know third time's the charm
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me
fool me three times oh my god they did
it three times in a row so thankfully it
seems like they're not gonna do that
and I know a lot of you are like hey
wait a minute what if this is Tom
Felton's character and he's playing the
reverse-flash well because this looks
like the Vampire Diaries actor I mean
they could totally be the case but it
looks like this Vampire Diaries actor so
I'm thinking that the Julianne thought
like the tom Felton character who's
gonna be working with Berry at the
police station is a totally different
character from this character here in
the reverse-flash costume so first big
reverse-flash that we have to talk about
from wally west era they've already done
zoom hunter zolomon was Wally West's
reverse-flash he was like a really close
friend that became an enemy but they've
already gone with the zoom name so they
have to use somebody else so even though
there's still a small chance that tom
Felton could be like an alternate
persona of a different flash from the
future or something like
I don't think that he is secretly the
reverse-flash of this season I think
it's gonna be this guy here we'll know
what his name is and it won't be a
secret he'll be like I am this character
and I'm not pretending to be anyone else
I'm the reverse-flash and I'm here to
kill everybody but which reverse-flash
is he well there's there's really like
three or four four actually technically
four reverse flashes that the show has
not done yet you could say he's edward
clariss the rival from the Jay Garrick
air from the Golden Age of the comics
you could say he's Thaddeus Thawne who
plays inertia he's more of Bart Allen's
reverse-flash and we haven't done Bart
Allen on the show yet Daniel West was
the reverse-flash of the new 52 he
actually had two different costumes and
one of them was kind of yellow looking
like this there's God speed
who is the new reverse flash in the
comics but he feels like a little too
fresh for them to be doing this soon so
I don't think he's God speed and then
there's Johnny quick who's kind of like
an alternate universe he's the crime
syndicate version of the flash so he's
like an alternate universe evil version
of the flash which they kind of did was
this kind of a zoom was he was like the
flash from earth to only he was evil so
he has to play the hunter zolomon zoom
card a little early because typically
like he would have been Wally West's
biggest reverse flash and they decided
to make him Barry Allen's enemy but he
has like a really easy name to grasp on
to zoom zoom is coming think about how
simple that idea is in the teaser just
instantly anybody who has never read
comics just understands that they're
like ozune okay that sounds like a
really catchy name so that's why I think
that this reverse flash will have a very
simple easy to grasp name the simplest
option could be just to call him the
black racer that might cause a little
confusion with the black flash from the
end of last season but his costume looks
a little bit like the black racer you
know plus the flash from the Darkseid
war run that Geoff Johns wrote on so
what happened is this is the costume I
mean it looks totally badass but it was
when Barry became the god of death the
black racer merged with Barry Allen and
this was what the costume looks like but
the problem with that character is that
he's a very new gods specific character
and I would be very surprised if they
did new gods stuff during season three
of the flash it would be amazing and I
would be very surprised so I'm not
expecting that but he's just somebody
that you have to add to the list so his
costume looks a
little bit like black racer a little bit
like Johnny quick a little bit like
Wally West air a little bit like Daniel
West just you know a combination of a
bunch of different things but if he's a
human person in the next big
reverse-flash that fits that profile
that has like a really simple name is
impulse
Thaddius Thawne he is part of the Thawne
lineage so again peat you know people
are familiar with the thoughts they know
eobard thawne is the reverse-flash from
seasons 1 & 2 so I know that they were
gonna do him eventually it's possible
that they just jumped him up the pecking
order and he's on this season which
actually you know people would wonder if
they were gonna do impulse maybe they're
gonna do Bart Allen too but that just
feels like too many versions of the
flash on the TV show at once like this
season is all about introducing Wally
West as the flash they haven't even
gotten to Jesse quick yet people are
like hey Wally got his powers does that
mean that Jesse quick is gonna get her
powers too that's like a whole other
thing in there have only been a couple
versions of the flash that have worn
black costumes there's the black flash
that we saw zoom turn into at the end of
last season but his chest symbol was
very different I mean a very different
costume this version of the costume
looks like like the headpiece almost
looks like something from Johnny quick
that he would wear trajectory actually
if you remember trajectory from last
season she wore a costume with lightning
on the shoulders that looked directly
inspired by Johnny quick but this
costume like the little like lightning
earpieces look very Wally West Mark Waid
era that era had like a lot of flashes
with really stylized earpieces that went
like way far off their heads combined
with some futures and like yellow daniel
west reverse-flash costume just like a
little more freakish looking but still
pretty cool and just in the name of
simplicity i think that they've given
him a name of a reverse flash that's
very simple to grasp like just just on
the outset look at this actor who does
he look like wow he definitely looks
like Eddie so it's totally possible that
he is Thaddeus Thawne he's impulse he's
part of the Thawne family and he just
has the aesthetics of a couple different
eras of the flash I would think it's
more likely that he's like a thought
like a familiar character that's
relatively human I would be less
surprised if he really is called the
black racer on the TV show but is part
of the Thawne family like he's Thaddeus
Thawne but instead of
calling himself inertia they just used
the name the black racer on the show I
would be blown away if he's part of the
New Gods I think just to make him an
easily graspable concept he's gonna be a
human character and just the name that
they give him could be up for grabs but
that's getting a little head of the
story you know first we have to find out
who this reverse flash is my guess is is
that we'll find out in the first two
episodes and they're not gonna tease you
with this mysterious backstory this is
what his goal is this is what he's doing
he's not secretly pretending to be
anyone else so they're just they're not
gonna repeat the arc of last season with
a villain that's trying to infiltrate
team flash so just for the purposes of
this video like I'm expecting them to
tease him at comic-con that he'll
probably be in the comic-con trailer
next week so we'll probably get that
name like it'll be like impulses coming
or it'll be some other version of the
reverse-flash so just to keep things
simple for now let me know in the
comments what do you think the name they
gave this reverse flashes do you think
he's gonna be impulse do you think he's
gonna be the black racer do you think
he's gonna be some other version of the
reverse flash and after we actually get
the name next week hopefully we'll get
the name next week we can talk more
about what he's doing like what his arc
was from the comics because like I said
they combined a lot of different
characters and eras from the comics so
there'll be a lot of Wally West Mark
Waid era stuff mixed with more modern
storylines but it's really cool and I
know it's weird that I didn't put the
pictures in my video here but
technically they're leaked so I just
wanted to keep this as speculative as
possible but we all know who we're
talking about so we'll probably see that
person next week we'll see some footage
we'll learn a little bit more about him
on the official level so because this
drops so suit like they announced wally
west it was very clear that they were
gonna announce him because they didn't
want this leak to get out they did not
say anything about the reverse-flash so
because this happens so soon I'm just
gonna keep the giveaway that I started
yesterday open so all you have to do to
enter that it'd just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video that will
be more DC this week because there's new
flash rebirth
so we'll just announce the winner for
that in a couple days when I post that
video while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
wally west costume reaction from
yesterday and you can
click here for my thor ragnarok pulp
teaser thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight